[Music]
in mindful finances news submitted to
their was submitted by too much kool-aid
the Japanese money-saving technique
called Kibo good Kibo can help you get
your finances together good combo I
don't even know and I'm Japanese yeah
I'm surprised it's not called Pokemon
gotta catch em all dollars sounds very
similar Kibo Oh
Campbell cut cable okay Oh dah okay Bobo
yeah so that's what that is
okay and it translates to or do you know
what it translates to nope translate
that households financial ledger doesn't
not one word Wow
the reason why it's hard to understand
it is don't take parts of a word and
combine it together to make one word
yeah so if it would be like [ __ ]
paragraph like an ax would probably be
called like stick blade strong things
well we just call it an axe or some [ __ ]
like that you know like it's like
they're at they're combining a bunch of
sounds that's not the whole word yes
okay bow chicka Bow it was invented in
1904 by a woman named Henny
Motoko who was notable for being Japan's
first female journalist and so this is a
simple no frills approach to managing
your finances and tell that to my
parents
nope they were the worst Japanese on
earth they so [ __ ] a love to spend
they sure love to spend weren't they
both artists too yeah yeah see told it
it went against their whole culture yep
there are types in all cultures there
there it is yep you do this the way you
do this method is or the whole purpose
of it is to be mindful of what you're
spending so they are saying that you
must ask yourself first of all you have
to write down every single item that
you're purchasing
and like by like physically writing it
with like a pen and paper writing it
down and that causes you to be fully
aware of what you're spending your money
on I'm tracking her mad girls but for
money yeah but not even digitally like
you have to write it yeah I said I just
type in a card you have to be very
conscious that you like actually spent
money today and you have to ask yourself
these questions and there are a few so
bear with me can I live without this
item yes based on my financial situation
can I afford it no will I actually use
it no never do I have the space for it
no how did I come across this in the
first place I see it in magazine did I
come across it after wandering in a gift
shop out of boredom it's not impulse
yeah what is my emotional state in
general today my calm stress celebratory
solution added by myself hoarder how do
I feel about buying it am I happy
excited indifferent and having last or
last forever so this is for impulsive
spenders that's what it sounds like okay
yeah so also more like Kokubo themed
strategies how come you didn't get
cookie bow down low to his brain
fraternal matrix is if there are other
strategies too about how to put a
percentage away and how to like only
spend this much on like living expenses
and [ __ ] like this specific thing it's
more about like being aware being
mindful of what you're spending yeah
yeah so then so then the other thing the
other list here that I have like it's
the strategies is number one leave the
item for 24 hours this highlights
whether you generally want or need it if
you're still thinking about the item the
next day and can't afford it then make
the purchase you'll feel a greater sense
of satisfaction about your decision I do
that with online shopping because
whenever it's like a sale from a store
that I really love I got put a bunch of
items in my cart cuz I just like the
feeling of shopping and then I leave it
and usually I forget about all those
items but if there's like something that
I can't forget like I really want that
they all go back we only get like one
package to our houses I spread out the
package
so it feels like I'm getting more
presents I'm just kidding [ __ ] up for
the packaging environment you're on time
out the other packages get sad negative
I know what you meant you're on time
yeah the transportation it's all humans
don't even come close to what companies
do bro it's fine I do that for like a
month cuz I realize like I can get
emotional and stay in emotional state
for like a few days yeah so one day like
Steve being on it for one day is not
enough if I'd wait like 30 days cuz you
obsess about the item for months yeah
research you're not doing and then
that's when you pay $80 for next day
shipping exactly yeah cuz I know that
about myself I'm like I gotta sleep on
things for a month yeah and then after a
month you don't want it then I know but
I thought there's percentages right so
it also depends on how much you
personally earn so for example let's say
if you make $1,000 a month right and
your [ __ ] impulse buying 500 worth of
things every month
50% of your income but let's say if you
make a million dollars a month and
you're going crazy every month on like
you know stupid [ __ ] that you're buying
but it's only like costing you 2,000 a
month that's a really small percentage
of your total income so that's what I go
based on you need it though because like
if you're like just collecting things
it's at Lehigh but just shoot in your
house like that's not good for your
housing but it's not but it's good for
the economy and there's other reasons I
mean it's like go ahead do what you want
to do but to be financially responsible
I think that's a better method for me
that percentages yeah is this helped
like live below your means and people's
means are all over the place cuz I like
organized chaos right cuz I don't like
limitations and I don't want to think
like that when I go to Vegas I want to
play no no yeah so I'm like okay well
let me create a system where I don't
regret this later
I could also and you just based off of
that instead of like every moment every
decision you're being limited exactly do
you know about this YouTube channel
called Graham Stefan yeah he's [ __ ]
awesome he's great but when you watch
like why he spends his money on and he's
like I live way below my means and he
buys like trash food
it's really bad I'm like oh well you
know and he makes fun of people that buy
Starbucks every day but I'm like no I
want a raise my means to like a cup of
cereal I know camps they're like extreme
couponers right they get off on saving
money and that's really fun to them and
I don't think they get the same
pleasures that we do when we consume
products that we enjoy some things that
I I splurged on like I like bottle
service I got I got bottle service some
water bottle service you're saying that
I should do like half bottle service
it's like I guess okay is your water
subscription to Sparkletts you just
don't drink speaking about sales that's
the second strategy that they put in
this article so number two is don't let
blowout sales tempt you so for this
person they write I used to be a sucker
for big sales but that often meant
spending money on items I knew I
wouldn't use so for each item that you
have in your basket during a sale ask
yourself whether you would buy advil if
it were true oh god that's true yeah if
it's Christmastime and me and Iggy or
Michaels we are [ __ ] it up cuz that's
a 50% off sale yeah oh and I would
normally buy that we destroyed Michaels
what are you arts and crafts [ __ ] oh
yeah I never see you cry oh it's
decorations oh that was first good but
no no I'm talking about last year huh
when we didn't have any Christmas
decorations we got you to destroy yeah
yeah yeah we got it like during
Halloween time and we like got like so
much Christmas yeah yeah yeah neither
before like way before or way after
Christmas is we we [ __ ] it up so hard
they had to call the bomb squad and then
they had to call them off don't get
their bingo flags you can't say bomb no
it's like an airport near and YouTube
environment alright next like no she's
joking cuz her channel got fired my
channel guys do monetize you know about
my channel got to monetize for being a
firearms channel a DIY firearms channel
what
oh the whole channel yeah and I got the
overheard and I got removed from my
network ha oh my I thought I was selling
firearms and teaching people how to
build the combo while you do they don't
know it's just cause she's hot I think
the robots just flagged it for so you
can't get it back no I got it back cuz
you're the bomb like YouTube thinks that
YouTube doesn't know why it happened my
audience was like maybe because you
always say your food's the bomb because
it's like literally cooking videos do
you think you do you say that yeah but
you can have firearms channels you just
can't be selling firearms or teaching
people how to build them obviously it's
that damn tasty Tuesday man lucky I
teaching people how to make sake bombs
that's what it is
huge shot at the Philip DeFranco thank
you for helping I thank you for helping
Phil Thank You star and scarce they all
help their community rose up I was
impressed well your your fitness guru
since when go to your Instagram yeah how
are you not a fitness person do you owe
your acceptance but you are you own a
gym and you don't want expensive I'm a
clown your shits like 90% I got money
fitness person he's like I have a goal
this year I'm doing a marathon that's
two he has more fitness posts than clown
pumps but I'd say I'm gonna run in a
very funny way listen you're putting an
image out and then you're rejecting your
own image it's like when girls I'll have
like booby photos and I'm a comedian
exactly like that that's not funny
that's horny yeah that's horny
thank you thank you Joe you know fun
fact about Japan though like they're so
scared of debt like the citizens there
that it's a it's a pretty cash heavy
society so everyone has a [ __ ] seasons
well let me let you do it okay what the
it's it's so bad to the point where the
banks aren't making money and they
having the part time giving out loans so
you could get a mortgage out there for
like point zero one percent
oh I'm just exaggerating but it's it's
like less than a percent we get alone
over there by a house over here no it
has to be there that would help there
that would help them true yeah well
people aren't getting loans is the
problem so that's always been a no
exactly right there government Joe tell
um yeah I mean they that would be a
better idea I'll put my money in your
bank you give me loans that's true I
think that's larceny or something it
sounds like we're creating a crime you
said a big word that I don't know what
it means so I'll believe you it's just I
didn't even use it over the phone it
just sounds cool I just thought of brie
Larson when you said that anyway go
ahead oh yeah so like just said spending
cash is one of the strategies because
physically handing over cash rather than
just mindlessly swiping your card makes
you more conscious of what you're
spending rid of those envelope systems
yeah those are like really big right now
where you have like an envelope for rent
you have an envelope for you budget oh
it all out and then you have cash in
those envelopes so you can physically
see what your budget is running great Oh
Oh see I got this pain in the ass Ridge
wallet that it's hard I can't get my
cards are you sponsored by them it's
kind of a yes cuz all because I can't
get my money and they'll be like I can't
remember if he said it was a PS are
really good and know what he's trying to
say is that he really likes it cuz it
makes him save money right cuz it's hard
to get your money up I see well you
should I think you [ __ ] you think
you're rich I said thank you [ __ ] thank
you
[Music]
[Music]